that does that shake your faith in
PlayStation the answer will vary but for
me no I don't look at that and go well
what's happening with Spider-Man 2 I'm
worried now but with Xbox fans that's
the cascading effect that happens every
time we looked at redfall what was the
first topic Cog that we got into
Starfield what's that what about Hellboy
hellblades ue5 that's graphically
intense it just immediately domino
effect right so that's the problem they
face is they can't just have isolated
issues they have
chain reactions because of years of just
not delivering to fans in your eyes but
at the same time you gotta take your
wins where you can they may not have the
exclusives to some but Game Pass is
working xcloud is has only grown more
and more the user bases grow more and
more so it's as I've got further from
the topic I still find it extremely
frustrating but I definitely expect Xbox
to ride this one out